[Musique]
maintenant à moscou le métro de moscou
est l'un des plus impressionnants du
monde n'attendait
[Musique]
cava vers chaque jour ils transportent 9
millions de passagers vous imaginez ça
[Musique]
le métro de moscou a ouvert en 1935 à
part un seul jour durant lequel il s'est
arrêté lors de la grande guerre
patriotique il n'a cessé de fonctionner
depuis
[Musique]
la construction du métro de moscou a
commencé avec la ligne rouge elle
comptait alors treize stations et
s'étendait sur 11 km le métro de moscou
a grandi est devenu avec le temps le
plus grand d'europe aujourd'hui il
dépasse les 400 km et se compose de 14
lignes desservant 278 stations il
devrait encore s'élargir jusqu'en 2024
le métro de moscou figure dans tous les
guides touristiques sur la russie ce
n'est pas seulement un musée souterrain
mais c'est aussi une sorte d'organisme
vivant qui fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 oui vous avez bien entendu
le métro fonctionne 24 heures sur 24
vérifions cela nous mêmes
le métro actuel est différent de ce que
j'ai vu quand je suis arrivé à moscou en
plus des lignes souterraines il possède
une seconde ligne circulaire du métro
aérien de 54 km
il y a deux ans le métro s'est encore
agrandie lorsque de nouvelles lignes ont
été lancés pour rejoindre les banlieue
de moscou
différentes lignes de métro sont reliés
par des correspondances comme par
exemple la station le gigot rock ska ya
dans laquelle je me trouve en ce moment
la fréquentation quotidienne de cette
station peut atteindre jusqu'à 600 mille
personnes
c'est le plus grand métro non seulement
de russie mais aussi d'europe les
travaux à grande échelle d'extension du
métro de moscou ont commencé en 2011 en
fait au cours des dix dernières années
nous avons réalisé 65 % du volume de ce
qui avait été construit les 80 années
précédentes en ce moment
carottes nouvelles stations sont en
train d'être construite à moscou
la construction du métro a même été
inscrite dans le livre guinness des
records pour le plus grand nombre de
complexes de tunneliers fonctionnant
simultanément
la station la plus profonde 84 mètres du
métro de moscou et parc pommé dit
[Musique]
cette ville souterraine compte environ
100 stations situées entre 29 et 65
mètres sous la surface
mais la plupart des nouvelles stations
sont généralement peu profondes
je voulais voir de mes propres yeux
comment se déroule la construction
aujourd'hui je vais voir de mes propres
yeux comment on construit une nouvelle
ligne de métro de moscou bolchaïa cole
c'est rien c'est un projet très
ambitieux
dans à peu près un an lorsque les
travaux seront terminés mot secours à la
plus longue ligne circulaire au monde
avant d'aller sur le chantier j'ai dû
mettre l'équipement nécessaire et
écouter les consignes de sécurité
la chose la plus étonnante est que tout
le processus de construction dépend
d'une seule dame elle s'appelle lilia et
on m'a conseillé de faire connaissance
avec elle grasset bonjour bonjour dites
moi s'il vous plaît où il y a on va les
rencontrer lé il ya bientôt comme
d'accord allons-y
à quelle profondeur cette situation
va-t-elle se trouvait
à une profondeur de 28 m de quoi dépend
la profondeur de la station cela dépend
de la profondeur du reste de la ligne
aujourd'hui on construit principalement
à moscou des stations peu profonde dans
ce cas les travaux sont réalisés par des
tranchées ouvertes comme nous pouvons
voir
on descend à l'est l'ampleur de ce
projet est stupéfiante il est difficile
d'imaginer que de telles stations peu
profondes soient construites en moyenne
en deux ans cette station emploie
actuellement environ 300 personnes il
travaille en équipe à tour de rôle pour
que le processus se poursuit 24 heures
sur 24 sept jours sur sept
tunnels et si grand il existe deux types
de tunnels le premier à une seule voie
dans lequel les trains circulent dans un
seul sens
et il ya également des tunnel
bidirectionnel comportant deux voies
celui là est un tunnel bidirectionnel
l' avantage de ce diamètre et que en
excavant une seule tranche et on
construit de voix à la fois ce qui
permet de gagner du temps et de réduire
les dépenses
ou il y a lilia nous attend c'est ainsi
que j'ai entamé mon voyage à travers le
tunnel selon les règles de sécurité je
ne devais pas me déplacer seule ici
alors on m'a assigné un accompagnateur
qui était censée mener à la mystérieuse
lilia
mais quelle surprise m'attendait tracé
bonjour bonjour
je cherche il y a quelle est la
ligne a est le nom du tunnelier qui
creuse ce tunnel
je vais vous présenter
entendu enchanté l'ia
le diamètre de lilia et 2,10 m elle est
presque deux fois plus grande que des
complexes similaires qui excaf des
tunnels pour la plupart des stations en
construction aujourd'hui 10 de ces dames
travaillent dans le métro pourquoi ce
tunnelier at il reçu un nom féminin
la tradition vient du canada le
propriétaire d'une société qui fabrique
des tunneliers avait décidé de nommer
toutes ces machines en l'honneur de
sainte barbe la sainte patronne des
mineurs d'autres pays ont adopté cette
idée ont commencé à doter les tunneliers
de prénoms féminins
l'ensemble du système de contrôle se
trouve ici
du bouclier en lui-même et de tous les
complexes
c'est la cabine de l'opérateur qui
pilote la machine à l'aide d'un système
de navigation
indique la direction pour assurer la
bonne pause du tunnel
les paramètres nécessaires pour
contrôler les régimes de percement
s'affiche sur ses deux écrans
et ces deux là sont pour la surveillance
vidéo
ce sont aussi des éléments très
importants de la machine
ils sont composés d'une roue de coups
tournante que nous ne pouvons pas voir
car elle est dans le sol grouptour et ça
c'est une chambre d'abattage ou les
matériaux sont évacuées dans le local
électrique il y à un sas pour le
personnel
des gens travaillent dans une pièce
pressurisé pour remplacer les molettes
musée
on voit aussi les système de vérins de
propulsion qui assure la progression du
tunnelier ils sont situés surtout le
diamètre du bouclier
on peut créer un autre élément essentiel
est un dispositif de pose de voussoirs
qui monte l'ensemble du tunnel en lui
même
c'est du ciment
quels matériaux
le voussoirs est en béton mais dans ce
tunnel là en raison des conditions
géologiques difficile il y à un
revêtement en métal
on a des nappe aquifère et les premiers
300 mètres du tunnel ont été posées sous
lens n'a gâtine ski c'est à dire sous
l'eau
on
[Musique]
se trouve à l'endroit où commence
l'assemblage du tunnel
quand le revêtement du tunnel et
transporté sur un véhicule spécial il
est chargé sur le dispositif de pose de
voussoirs à l'aide d'une grue bon et
ensuite la machine de pose de voussoirs
elle se trouve juste au dessus de nos
têtes qu'on le voue soir et l'installent
au bon endroit au moins
peut-on construire un tunnel au dessus
d'un autre bord et honnête sinisco cas
tonnelle cela arrive systématiquement à
moscou il faut parfois passer sous les
tunnels existants pour rejoindre
différentes lignes
il ya creuse à une vitesse moyenne de 14
mètres par jour tout dépend du type de
sol
le processus est plus rapide s'il s'agit
de sable plus lent lorsqu'il est
nécessaire de creuser de l'argile
et où va la terre creusée par les liens
elle est envoyée à la surface à l'aide
d'une bande de transport spécial puis
transporté hors de la ville par camion
quand j'ai vu comment ces gens
écrivaient avec leurs propres mains
l'histoire du métro de moscou j'ai voulu
y prendre part moi aussi hot line
installée voilà on m'a donné ça pour
vous merci
je peux essayer oui bien sûr
[Musique]
et
bien voilà c'est le moment de contribuer
au développement du métro de moscou
ça y est voilà ça restera ici pour
toujours
à mes gosses c'est une autre station qui
fera partie de la grande ligne
circulaire elle sera bientôt ouverte et
nous serons parmi les premiers à nous y
trouver allons-y la station voronov sky
à se distinguera par son extraordinaire
plafond 3d qui doit symboliser la voie
lactée
j'ai eu la chance de parler à
l'architecte qui a conçu la station
comment choisissez-vous le style de la
station
vous savez à vrai dire c'est un
processus difficile
cela peut prendre deux mois trouver une
source d'inspiration comprendre à quoi
cela doit ressembler il faut parfois
énormément de croquis et de dessin pour
que cela avance
d'une manière ou d'une autre on arrive
aux enfants en résultats si je comprends
bien ce n'est pas votre première station
non on a déjà travaillé sur d'autres
stations auparavant elles sont très
différentes
oui on nous donne la liberté de créer
tout ce qu'on veut nous ne sommes pas
obligés de faire des stations de métro
des copies chaque projet est intéressant
futuriste a sa propre interprétation de
divers styles architecturaux et son
individualité vous avez créé un espace
dans la ville qui restera là pour plus
de 100 ans qu'est ce que ça signifie
pour vous pour moi la création de chaque
station ressemble à la naissance
d'enfants j'espère que cet héritage
perdurera pour les passagers du métro
ainsi que pour mes descendants vorontsov
sky a est la première station du métro
de moscou construite dans le style
paramétrique
c'est une direction de mouvement
futuriste que certains architectes appel
post industrielle ou style de l'ère
numérique
le métro est une véritable ville
souterraine dans laquelle la vie est
aussi actif qu'à la surface il accueille
divers événements et même des
compétitions sportives il y a quelques
jours il ya eu un marathon mais c'est un
événement tout à fait différent de celui
auquel j'ai participé au baïkal et
aujourd'hui je vais rencontrer le
vainqueur
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
grâce à sa merci d'être venus
racontez moi ce que c'est que ce
marathon du métro
c'est un événement organisé par le métro
de moscou
la tâche consiste à parcourir
l'itinéraire couple du métro en le moins
de temps possible
pour le faire il faut passer par
certains points de contrôle qui sont
situés au terminus des lignes du métro
enregistré son arrivée à ses stations là
puis se rendre au point de départ il y
avait combien de stations 21 points de
contrôle le départ l'arrivée et 19
station terminus
comment avez-vous appris l'existence de
ce marathon je suis les informations
publiées par le département des
transports c'était la première fois que
je prenais part à un tel événement j'ai
vu que ça allait être organisée et j'ai
décidé que c'était une bonne manière de
passer le temps j'ai réalisé le trajet
en 16h34
je vous propose de faire une compétition
allez donc je vais par là et vous par là
on se voit plus tard
étant donné qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
marathon traditionnel
l'administration du métro a demandé
l'assistance de l'institut de physique
et de technologie de moscou qui a
développé le meilleur itinéraire et l'a
mis en ligne pour téléchargement
les experts ont appliqué le principe de
commis voyageur qui calcule le chemin le
plus court pour parcourir la distance
souhaité et revenir au point de départ
c'est le principe qui va n'a choisi moi
au contraire je n'ai pas suivi
l'itinéraire particulier j'ai
régulièrement fait des arrêts
saviez vous que le métro est un
véritable musée de paléontologie
j'ai même pu trouver quelque chose
d'intéressant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est pour la chance
ce sont des portes hermétique elles ont
été installées en 1941 pendant la grande
guerre patriotique le métro servaient
d'abris anti aériens il y avait tout la
magasin salon de coiffure bibliothèque
et même une maternité pendant la guerre
plus de 200 bébés sont nés dans le métro
[Musique]
un peu en retard vous mme attendait
depuis longtemps
oui je suis arrivé il ya longtemps
comment avez vous choisi votre
itinéraire je savais à l'avancé quels
itinéraires j'allais prendre
vous avez dû faire un détour au début
vous pouvez commencer n'importe quand
mais cela n'a aucun sens de commencer
après 8 heures du matin il faut
commencer tôt le matin dès que le métro
ouvre cela vous permet de gagner du
temps
votre record était de 16 heures et
combien de minutes
34 minutes
j'ai aussi appris que mon nouvel ami
collectionnait les cartes de transport
troïka
il y à 370 carte dans sa collection et
certaines d'entre elles sont des
exclusivités comme celle ci avec hideo
kojima le concepteur de jeux japonais à
moscou seulement 15 cartes comme celles
ci ont été émises
[Musique]
pas d'embarquement veuillez descendre
bas d'embarquement
je suis arrivé à l'un des vingt ateliers
du métro de moscou
ici on assure toute sorte d'entretien et
de révision des trains
[Musique]
oui
certains trains sont conduits par des
femmes dans le métro de moscou elles ne
sont que 12
le fait est que dans les années 80 en
urss la profession de conducteur de
train et est considérée comme dangereuse
et interdite aux femmes
il ya six mois elles ont à nouveau été
autorisée à conduire les trains
faisons connaissance avec l'une d'elles
le
bonjour bonjour
quel bout en train de faire je suis en
train d'inspecter le matériel roulant
avant de le mettre sur sa ligne il est
interdit de mettre sur sa ligne un train
qui auraient des défauts de
fonctionnement vous êtes l'une des
premières femmes autorisées à conduire
une rame de métro
c'est vrai j'ai travaillé comme son chef
de station de métro
mon mari est conducteur donc j'avais un
exemple à suivre et lorsqu'on a annoncé
un concours pour un premier groupe de
femmes afin de les former en tant que
conductrice de train je n'ai pas hésité
une seconde
le reste du personnel sont des hommes
qu'en pensez vous
au début tout le monde était surpris et
quelque peu méfiants parce que c'est
inhabituel
des femmes conduisant des trams c'est
quelque chose d'ordinaire on en voit
tous les jours dans les rues personne ne
trouve cela curieux mais des femmes qui
conduisent un matériel roulant qui
pèsent plusieurs tonnes ça paraît
extraordinaire
mais je peux toujours compter sur des
coups de main aux nomades jamais dit non
avant de mettre le train sur la ligne le
conducteur doit s'assurer que tout est
en ordre à l'intérieur
[Musique]
ce que cache rien de temps dure votre
journée de travail le temps de travail
maximale est de huit heures et demie le
temps minimal est de 6 heures il ya une
norme spéciale pour le nombre d'heures
de travail par mois mais la durée d'une
journée de travail peu varié
si vous terminez à 3 heures du matin
lorsque le métro est déjà fermée si on a
un quart de nuit on ne revient pas à la
maison soit on laisse le train sur la
ligne pour un arrêt de nuit soit on le
conduit à l'atelier dans les ateliers il
ya des salles de repos pour les équipes
les trains et si on stationne le train
sur sa ligne il y à un transport spécial
pour les conducteurs qui vient les
chercher à différentes stations pour les
amener à l'atelier
habituellement plusieurs rames se trouve
dans les tunnels le sorte que le trafic
commence aux stations exactement au
moment de l'ouverture le métro ouvre à
5h30 et il est nécessaire que les
premiers passagers entament leur trajet
à peu près au même moment sans attendre
que la première rame arrive à leur
station après avoir quitté l'atelier
vous êtes habituellement toute seule
dans la cabine non j'ai un assistant
en quoi consiste son travail
l'assistant contrôler les cheveux de
signalisation les aiguillages et la
valve de freinage comme
vous allez se met en situation d'urgence
ils activent le cidal d'alarmé qui
provoque le freinage du train
je voulais vous demander s'il serait
possible de me laisser conduire la ram
jusqu'à ma station non malheureusement
ce n'est pas possible d'accord merci à
vous
[Musique]
bon courage christina
saviez vous que le métro de moscou
emploi le deuxième plus grand nombre de
femmes au monde à la première place se
trouve ma ville natale mexico
christina travail sur la ligne bleue la
première ligne de tout le métro avoir
été posée à la fois sous terre et en
surface
le conducteur est toujours en contact
avec ce qui contrôle le fonctionnement
du métro à partir du centre de contrôle
[Musique]
il y à plus de 800 spécialistes de
différents profils qui assure le bon
fonctionnement du métro de là il
surveille la circulation des trains le
fonctionnement des escaliers mécaniques
la sécurité aux stations et
l'infrastructure du métro dans son
ensemble ces gens voient tous
mais même eux peuvent parfois être
surpris
récemment un spider man est apparu à
moscou
personne ne sait qui il est ni pourquoi
il fait ça
[Musique]
mais c'est un drôle de type
avant
[Musique]
le service de sécurité ne m'a pas permis
de parler à mon super héros préférés
dans le métro
j'ai trouvé un moyen de le faire
on dit que mes cameramen et moi
organisions un site pour le tournage
notre nouvel ami n'a pas perdu son temps
et il a donné un vrai spectacle
[Musique]
la can est enfin spider man
je ne savais pas qu'ils étaient russes
comment as tu réussi à faire tellement
de bruit sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
comme ça que j'ai trouvé j'ai commencé à
saint pétersbourg
nous étions 5 je faisais partie d'un
groupe et puis j'ai essayé de faire ça
tout seul d'aller danser dans le métro
d'abord c'était sans ce costume mais
plus tard j'ai décidé de porter un
costume et comme tout le monde connaît
spider man tu viens de saint pétersbourg
et tu as compris qu'il manquait un super
héros à moscou c'est ça ici je n'ai pas
de concurrent pourquoi tu fais ça
je suis un danseur de breakdance je suis
aussi acrobates autodidacte c'est de
l'improvisation tout ça où tu sais à
l'avancé ce que tu vas faire
oui tout et répéter les performances que
tu fais tu les a conçus toi même
oui je fais tout par moi même voilà
comment cela se déroulent d'habitude
je monte dans un wagon et personne ne me
remarque il regarde tous leurs
téléphones je mets de la musique est là
tout le monde réagit et puis le show
commence
le monde prend des photos
oui ça leur remonte le moral
spider man fait sourire les gens
ils savent tous qu'il est bon que ce
personnage est un ami je provoque des
émotions positives chez des gens pour
qu'ils puissent les partager avec leurs
proches
et certains passagers ce sont plutôt des
gens plus âgés ou des femmes ne
comprennent pas ça elles me font aux
cancans jambes quand je danse et puis
parfois il me frappe
comment réagissent les agents de
sécurité du métro
et me surveille toujours où que je sois
ils sont là aussi et dans la plupart des
cas c'est très calme sans incident
la sécurité est l'une des priorités de
la direction du métro
récemment un système de reconnaissance
faciale a été mise en service et environ
900 criminels ont été appréhendés au
cours des six premiers mois
d'utilisation
et en plus l'ordre dans le métro est
maintenue par ces gens là
[Musique]
mes amis aujourd'hui je ne vous ai
montré qu'une petite partie de ce que
représente le métro de moscou
il est énorme et multiforme c'est en
même temps un musée un lieu de travail
et une scène
pour moi le métro fait partie de moscou
sans lequel je ne peux tout simplement
pas imaginer cette ville
à une heure du matin le métro ferme et
sa vie nocturne commence les équipes de
nettoyage et d'entretien se met au
travail il y a environ 40 nettoyeur à
chaque station et chacun doit laver
plusieurs centaines de mètres carrés le
dernier train débarquent les derniers
passagers à 1h41
mais le métro continue de fonctionner
toute la nuit
[Musique]